9. sınıfın son ünitesine başlıyoruz.
Hangisindeyiz? Nanoteknoloji ve
sürdürülebilirlik diye bir konu.
Nanoteknoloji nedir? Nanoteknolojik
parçacıklar nasıl elde ediliyor? Buradan
sürdürülebilirliğe nasıl geçiş
yapacağız? Baba nasıl bir bağlantısı
var? Bunların hepsinden bahsedeceğim ama
birkaç videoda bahsedeceğim tabii ki.
Şimdi nanoteknoloji nedir? Bundan
bahsedeceğim bu derste. O zaman vakit
kaybetmiyoruz. Hazırsak başlayalım.
Nanoteknolojiye önce metal nano
parçacıklar diye bir başlıkla başlıyorum
ama önce nanoteknolojiyi tabii ki burada
detaylı bir şekilde anlatacağım. Sonra
metal nano parçacıklardan da
bahsedeceğim tabii ki. Nano nano
dediğimiz boyut çok küçük bir boyuttur.
Yani metrenin milyarda biri dediğimiz
boyuttur. Yani 1 x 10 üzeri -9 m
dediğimiz bir şey çok küçüktür. Şöyle
söyleyeyim. 1 nanometre aşağı yukarı 10
tane hidrojen atomunun yan yana
gelmesiyle oluşan mesafedir. Bu kadar
küçük bir şeyden bahsediyoruz. İşte bu
boyutlar üzerinde çalışılan sistemler
vardır. Biz buna nanoteknoloji diyoruz
ama tabii ki 1 nanometreyle mi
çalışıyorlar? Hayır. Aşağı yukarı işte
100 nanometreye kadarki bir süreci
işliyor. İşte bu aralığı işleyen, bu
şekilde çalışan sistemler nanoteknoloji
olarak ifade ediliyor. Burada da şöyle
söylüyor. İşte maddeyi atomik veya
moleküler seviyede kontrol altına alma
bilimine nanoteknoloji ismini veriyoruz.
Tabii ki burada kimyanın çok büyük
katkısı vardır. Çünkü nanoteknolojik
malzemeleri üret üretenler kimyacılardır
genel olarak. Şimdi nanoteknolojik
çalışmalarda neler vardı? işte maddenin
nano boyuttaki yapılara müdahale edip
daha işlevsel hale getirilmesini ve bu
şekilde yeni teknolojik ürünlere entegre
edilmesini sağlıyor. Mesela örnek
vereyim. Nano boyalar vardır.
Nanoteknolojik boyalar vardır. Yüzeye
sürdüğünde yüzeyi o kadar pürüzsüzdür ki
yani nanoteknolojik olarak yapılmıştır.
Nano boyutta orada boyar maddeler vardır
ve yüzey o kadar pürüzsüzdür ki kir
tutunamaz. Veya işte rüzgarla bile o
yüzeydeki kirler uçabiliyor. Yüzeye bir
şey tutunamadığı için de ne oluyor? İşte
gayet temiz kalıyor o bölge. İşte
nanoteknolojik boyalar mesela buna örnek
olarak verebilirim. İşte bu
nanoteknolojik çalışmalar sonucunda
temiz enerji kaynaklarından iklim
değişikliğine, temiz sudan hayat
kurtarıcı ilaçlara kadar birçok şey
geliştirilmiştir. Kiş bu nanoparçacıklar
nerelerde kullanılıyor dediğimizde
elektronik sektöründe yoğun bir şekilde
kullanılıyor. Tıp sektöründe kullanıyor.
Mesela grafen dediğimiz şey o
nanoteknoloji üzerinden geliştirilmiş
bir şeydir. Tıp sektöründe yine aynı
şekilde nano böyle ilaçlar vardır. Nano
robot dediğimiz sistemler vardır. Vücuda
gönderiliyor. sadece hastalık bölgesine
müdahale edecek ilaçlar şeklinde
geliştirmeye de devam ediliyor.
Bunlardan da bahsedeceğim.
Detaylayacağım zaten. Çok ilginç
çalışmalar var. Çok güzel çalışmalar var
gelecek nanoteknolojide. Başka neler
var? Mesela tekstil var ki bu ıslanmayan
kumaşlar vardır. Yağmur yağıyor, üzeri
bir şey olmuyor. Islanmıyor veya işte
kir tutmuyor. Üzerine çamur atıyorlar.
Üzerinden akıp gidiyor. Hatta bunun
spreyleri falan da satılıyor. Ayakkabıya
falan sıktığında ne oluyor? su tutmuyor.
İşte bunlar nanoteknolojiyle
geliştirilmiş ürünlerdir. E tarım
sektöründe, kozmetik sektöründe, gıda
sektöründe de yine nanoteknoloji yoğun
olarak kullanılmakta. Bak günlük hayatta
örnek vermiş burada yine şu anda cep
telefonuyla seyrediyorsan beni veya cep
telefonu yanındaysa ekranında böyle bir
kaplama oluyor. Ben işte nanofilm
kaplattım falan diyorlar. İşte bu
ifadeler kullanılıyor incecik. Ne
oluyor? Telefonu koruyor değil mi?
Düştüğünde mesela ne oluyor? O
kırılıyor. Alttaki katmanı koruyor.
Üzerinde bazen ceviz kıranlar falan
filan. Böyle artis artis şeyler yapanlar
var da siz yapmayın onu. Gerçeği olmaz
falan filan. Sıkıntı yaşarsın yani.
Bundan dolayı şey var işte
nanoteknolojiyle üretilmiş bir ürün. Bu
nanoteknolojiyle üretilmiş bir ürün
olduğu için ne oluyor? Yüzeyi koruyor.
Mesela başka ne var? Bu aynalar,
nanofilm camlar var. Mesela bu şeylere,
e araçların aynalarına falan
yerleştiriliyor. Yağmur tutmuyor mesela.
Ne oluyor? Yolu rahatlıkla
görebiliyorsun. Bundan ben de alayım bir
tane. Bak benim arabaya da ihtiyaç
varmış bundan. İşte ıslanmayan, kir
tutmayan, kendini temizleyen tekstil
ürünleri, renk değiştiren, sıcaklığa
duyarlı olarak renk değiştiren
sistemler, elektronik tekstil şeyleri,
giyilebilir teknolojiler falan da var ya
bununla ilgili. Belki ileride çok böyle
değişik şeyler yapılacak. İşte vücutta
bir yere işte bağlantı kuracaksın. Cep
telefonunu cebindeyken şarj edecek
kablosuz olarak. Olamaz mı? Olabilir.
Yani örnek veriyorum işte gömleğin cebi
yerleştirdin, telefon şarj olmaya
başladı. Olamaz mı? Olabilir. Böyle bir
sistemde geliştirebilir veya işte
ayakkabılardan oradan mesela elektrik
enerjisi elde edip vücuttaki işte
bağlantı yaparak başka şeyleri şarj
edebilir. Yani olamaz mı? Olabilir. İşte
bunlar nanoteknolojiyle mümkün. Mesela
su geçirmeyen yara bantları böyle çok
ince. Bununla ilgili de çeşitli
çalışmalar var. Mesela tıpta görüntüleme
alanında bu şekilde çalışmalar var ki
bak burada gösteriyor işte. diyor ki
dalga boyları farklı ışımalar yapılarak
renk değiştiren kuantum nokta ki bunlar
karbon elementi ile yapılıyor. İşte nano
parçacıklar tıpta görüntüleme amaçlı
kullanılmaktadır. Veriliyor mesela
canlıya. O gidiyor vücutta işte
istenilen bölgede tutunuyor. Ondan sonra
şey yaptıklarında, ışın verdiklerinde o
bölge görülebiliyor. Mesela bak burada
faredeki belirli bölgeyi tespit etmek
için bunu kullanmışlar. Bak burada
görüyor musun? Sadece o bölgede böyle
bir ışıma oluyor. Onu fark ediyorlar.
İşte nanoparçacıklarla bu şekilde ne
yapıyorlar? hastalıkları teşhis
edebiliyorlar. Başka ileride belki şöyle
bir şey olacak. İnşallah bulunur.
Kanserli hücreye mesela saldıracak.
Sadece kanserli hücreye saldırılacak.
Gidecek ona tutunacak mesela dışarıdan
ışın gönderdiğinde o bölgeyi böyle yok
edecek. Olamaz mı? Olabilir. Yani
ileride böyle şeyleri de göreceğiz.
Başka işte bunlara nanoajan diyorlar.
Vücuda gönderdiğinde belki sadece o
hastalıklı bölgeyi yakalayan veya sadece
hastalığın olduğu bölgeyi tedavi eden
sistemler geliştirilebilir. Mesela bak
demin söylediğim işte burada gösteriyor.
Diyor ki kanser hücre ile demir
nenoparçacık ile dıştan tespit
yapılabiliyor. Böyle bir şey mümkün.
Yani gönderiyorsun kanser hücreye
tutunuyor bunlar. Dışarıdan da tespit
edilebiliyor. Başka ne var mesela? İşte
burada gösteriyor. Kuantum nokta o
karbon parçacıklarıydı ve altın nan o
parçacıkların taşıdığı işte bunları
alıyor o bölgeye yapışıyor. Sonra
dışarıdan ısı veya ışıkla ne yapıyor? O
kanserli hücreleri öldürebiliyorlar. Bak
bu teknoloji başlamış. Daha da gelişecek
inşallah. Mesela tümörlü hücrenin
büyümesini engelleyen nanoparçacıklar,
nanobotlar. Nanorobot dediğimiz mesela
bazı moleküller var. O moleküller öyle
bir yerleşiyor ki böyle hareket
edebiliyor. Sanki böyle bir robot gibi
hareket edebiliyor. İşte bunu
nanoteknolojiyle başarıyorlar. veya
diyelim işte damar içine oksijen
taşıyan, diş temizliği yapan bu şekilde
nano robotlar yapılabilir. Hatta işte
bana bazen yazıyorlar yorumlarda
görüyorum çok benzediğimi falan
söylüyorlar. Bilmiyorum benziyor mu
benzemiyor mu da işte şey var Tony Stark
diyorlar ya ne yapıyor mesela yürürken
göğsüne şöyle bir bastırıyor. Neyde End
Game End Game filmindeydi değil mi?
Evet. Avengers End Game'de böyle yok End
Game'de değildi la neredeydi? Sonsuzluk
Savaşındaydı. He yanlış söyledim. Oradan
böyle bir basıyor böyle ne yapıyor?
Vücudu kaplıyor o Iron Man kıyafeti.
Sonra kim soruyordu? İşte o halkı
oynayan adam soruyordu. Bu ne falan
diye. Nanitlerle yaptım. Nano robotlar
falan filan diye söylüyor ya işte. Yani
o kadar abartılı bir şey değil. Ama
sonuç olarak bak orada filmde
nanoteknolojiyi gösteriyor. Göğsüne
basıyor, vücudunu kaplamaya başlıyor
falan filan. Bu tabii abartılı bir şey
de ama bak günümüzde de ne yapıyorlar?
Nanobotlar geliştiriyorlar. Bunlarla
vücuda gönderdiklerinde hastalıklı
hücreleri falan yok edebiliyorlar.
Mesela bak, dolaşım, boşaltım, sindirim
gibi metabolik faaliyetlerini
gerçekleştiren nano boyuttaki yapay
organların çiplere entegre edilmesiyle
ne yapıyorlar? Aslında bir çeşit böyle
dijital veya işte böyle robotik organlar
gerçekleştiriyorlar. Bunları sistemler
yapıyorlar. İşte oluşturulan bu
sistemler üretim aşamasındaki bazı
ilaçların gelişimi ve verimliliğini
denetlemek için yapılıyor. Ne yapıyor?
Yapıyorlar bunu. İlacı veriyorlar. Nasıl
etki yapıyor, nasıl alıyor falan bunları
tespit ediyorlar. Hatta şöyle bir şey
var. nanoorganlarla kimya laboratuvarı
gibi yani içerisinde bir sürü şey deneyi
falan filan şeyi böyle nasıl söyleyeyim
analizi falan yapıp sonuç
ulaştırabiliyor. Ona göre işte vücuda
belki şeyle bu teknolojik aletlerle
uyarılar verebiliyor ki bu var mesela şu
anda vücuda takılıyor bir şeyle
takılıyor. Kanı alıyor kanı analiz
ediyor. Orada kan şekerini belirliyor.
Kan şekerini belirledikten sonra vücuda
bağlı bir sistem var mesela. oraya uyarı
gönderiyor. O gönderdiği uyarıyla vücuda
mesela insülin veriliyor. Bu şekilde
mesela yapılan sistemler var zaten. Şu
anda kullanılıyor. Sadece kan şekerini
ölçmek için kullananlar da var. Kolunun
arkasına falan takıyorlar. İşte onu
taktıktan sonra saatiyle, telefonuyla
falan kontrol ediyor. Bir bakıyor, "A
kan şekerim düşmüş, insülin vuruluyor
mesela." Bu şekilde işte bak şu anda
bunlar kullanılıyor zaten. İçerisinde
böyle küçük şeyler var. Resmen bir kimya
laboratuvarı var. Orada ne yapıyor?
analizi yapıyor. Sonucu hemen şeye
dönüştürüyor. İşte sisteme gönderiyor.
Sistemde işte telefona, saate falan
filan gönderiyor. Bu şekilde ne yapıyor
dostum? Sağlıklı yaşamına devam etmeye
çalışıyor. Yani en azından hayat
kalitesi yükselmiş oluyor. Bak burada da
bir tane örnek göstermiş. Bu çip organ
dediğimiz şey şunlar işte. İçerisine
mesela giriyor. O vücut sıvısı, kan veya
başka bir şey. Neyse artık burada
analizleri gerçekleştiriyorlar. Bu bir
tane çipi. Tabii ki bu sistem bu şekilde
basit değil de daha bir bir sürü
bağlantıları var mesela. Bunlarla ne
yapıyorlar? İşte böyle komplike bir
sistem yapıyorlar. Bak soruda diyor ki,
"Nanoteknoloji ile ilgili ifadelerinden
hangileri doğrudur?" Hım, bakalım. Şimdi
maddelerin sadece fiziksel
görünümlerinin değiştirilmesi esasına
dayanır. Hayır, sadece fiziksel değil,
kimyasal görünümlerinin de değişimi,
kimyasal özelliklerinin de değişimi
vardır burada. Sadece fiziksel değildir.
Malzeme olarak boyutları oldukça küçük
olan parçacıkların ki bunlara nano
parçacıkları diyoruz. Kullanıldığı
teknolojidir. Evet, nanoteknoloji buydu.
Maddenin çekirdek yapısının
değiştirildiği hayronükleer
reaksiyonlarda oluyordu. Burada yoktur.
Çekirdek yapısı değiştirilmez. O yüzden
cevap yalnız 2 olmalı. Yani A seçeneği.
Burada diyor ki, "Nanoparçacıklar
kullanılarak elde edilen hammaddelerden
hangileri elde edilebilir?" Bakalım.
Şimdi bu ham maddelerden su tutmayan
kumaş yapılıyor. Nanoteknolojiyle
üretilen şeylerden yapılıyor bu.
Hastalığı teşhis, hastalıklı hücreyi
teşhis edebilen görüntüleme cihazı.
Evet, bunda da kullanıyoruz. Kontrolsüz
büyüyen hücrelere müdahale eden
nanorobotlar. Bu neydi? şeyleri,
tümörleri falan durduruyordu. Doğru.
Çizilmeyen telefon ekranları nano
ekranlarda var. Bu da var. O zaman ne
oldu? Hepsi oldu. Cevap da E seçeneği.
Şimdi nanoteknoloji dediğimizde o nano
dediğimiz boyut var ya çok küçük boyut.
Nanometre neydi? İşte metrenin milyarda
biri dediğimiz bir ifadeydi. İşte 1
metreye 1 milyar nanometre ifadesini
kullanabilirsin. Çok küçük bir şeydir.
İşte büyüklüğü 1 nanometre ile 100 nanom
arasında olan ya da işte 10 üzeri -9'ile
10 üzeri -7 met arasında olan
parçacıklara biriz nano parçacık
ifadesini kullanıyoruz. E bunlarla
ilgilenen teknoloji de nanoteknoloji
oluyor. İşte çok küçük bir ölçü birimi
olduğu için haliyle nanometrenin
boyutunu anlamak için şöyle örnekler
vermek lazım. Bak, DNA. DNA'nın boyutu 2
ile 2,5 nanom arası. Görmemiz mümkün
değil zaten. Başka grip virüsü bak 20
nanometreymiş. Hücre zarı 12
nanometreymiş. Demek ki işte grip virüsü
hücre zarından biraz daha büyük. Sonuçta
bir o da bir çeşit hücre. Hücrenin zarı
haliyle ondan daha küçük olacaktır. Saç
teline bakar mısın? Neymiş? 80.000
nanometre. Bunu zaten az da olsa
görebiliyoruz. Gözümüz görebiliyor. Bu
ne oluyor? 80 mikrometre mi oluyor? Öyle
bir şey galiba. Yani sonuçta saç teli
fark edilebiliyor. Bak bunu
nanometreyile ifade etmek aslında çok mu
doğru değil. Sonuçta 80.000 nanometre.
Bir biraz daha uğraşsak görebilir hale
geliyoruz zaten. Ama şunları mesela asla
gözümüz göremez. Bunları ancak ve ancak
elektron mikroskobu dediğimiz özel bir
mikroskopla görebiliriz. Şunu mesela
ışık mikroskobuyla görebiliriz. Belki
biraz zorlasak gözümüzle de görürüz. E
haliyle işte nano boyuttaki çok çok çok
küçük boyuttakileri görmek için çeşitli
görüntüleme sistemleri vardır ki
birazdan bahsedeceğim. Ha demin
söylemiştim bunu. Hidrojen atomunun
yaklaşık işte 01 nanometre olduğunu
düşündüğümüzde ne oluyor? 10 tane
hidrojen atomu 1 nanometre ediyor.
Mesela su molekülü mesela 0,25
nanometredir. 1/4 nanometredir. O zaman
ne olacaktır? 4 tane su molekülü yan
yana geldiğinde 1 nanometre gibi
düşünebiliriz. işte ne kadar küçük
olduğunu söylemek için, ifade etmek için
bunları söylüyorum. Ha bak burada işte
si birimlerine göre kıyaslaması var. Ne
oluyor? İşte metreyi işte ne diye
gösteriyoruz? 10 üzeri 0. Ne oluyor?
Desimetre dediğimiz 10 üzeri -1. cm
dediğimiz ne oluyor? İşte %1'i 10 üzeri
-2 böyle gidiyor. İşte pikometre var,
nanometre var. Bak nanometre şurada
işte. Zaten genellikle biz bu boyutla
ilgileneceğiz. Şimdi kıyaslamayile
ilgili bakalım. Diyor ki boyu 50 cm olan
bir telin uzunluğu kaç nanometredir? Bak
şimdi santimetre şurada. Ben bunu
nanometre olarak ifade etmek istiyorum.
Arada kaç fark var? 10 üzeri 7'lik bir
fark var. Görüyor musun? Ha. O zaman 50
cmyi ne yapacağım? X 10 üzeri 7
dediğimde ne olarak ifade etmiş
olacağım? 5 x 10 üzeri - değil pardon
eksi olmayacak artı olacak tabii ki. 10
üzeri 8 nanometre şeklinde ifade
edebiliriz. Aşağı giderken çarpıyorsun
yukarıya doğru çıkarken ise bölüyorsun.
Burada diyor ki bak boyu 2 x 10 üzeri -6
mm olan DNA molekülünün boyu kaç
nanometredir? Bak şimdi hemen geldim
buraya. Milimetre ile nanometre
arasındaki farka bakalım. 10 üzeri -3 10
üzeri -9 Aşağı doğru gidiyorum. 10 üzeri
6'lık bir fark var. He o zaman demek ki
2 x 10 üzeri -6 mm x 10 üzeri 6
dediğimizde nanometreye çeviriyorum ya o
zaman 2 nanometre boyutuna ulaşmış
oluyor. Aşağıya giderken bu şekilde
yukarıya giderkense böleceğim. Bak diyor
ki burada çapı 100.000 nanomet. 100.000
nanometre dediğimiz 10 üzeri 5
nanometreden bahsediyor. Hah. Olan saç
telinin kalınlığı kaç milimetredir?
Dikkat et. Bu sefer ne yapıyorum?
Nanometreden milimetreye çıkıyorum.
Militre diyecektim lan. Heh. Aradaki
fark 10 üzeri 6. Ne yapıyordum? Yukarı
çıkarken bölüyordum. Yani 10 üzeri 5/ 10
üzeri 6 sonuç 1/10 yani 0,1 mm şeklinde
ifade ediyoruz dostum. Bak diyor ki
burada nanometre ölçekli bir cetvel ile
boyu 1,5 metre olan bir kişinin boyunu
ölçmek uygun olur mu? Y arkadaş bak 1,5
metre kaç nanometre ediyor? Bak dur la
he yazamadım. 1,5 m e 1 metre neydi işte
milyarda biriydi nanometre. O zaman ne
yapacağım? 10 üzeri 9'ile çarpacağım. E
1,5 x 10 üzeri 9 nanomet. La düşünsene
cetveli şöyle koydun üzerinde 1,5 x 10
üzeri 9 nanometre yani çizgiler
çizeceksin. Böyle bir çizgi çizerek
ölçmeye çalışacaksın. Ya 1,5 metrelik
bir şeyi yani boyutları büyük olan bir
şeyi, gözümüzün görebileceği bir şeyi
nanometre cetveliyle ölçmek mümkün
müdür? Hayır değildir dostum. O yüzden
uygun olur mu? Olmaz diyoruz. 5'te diyor
ki bak atom, ökaret, hücre, DNA ve
organerden hangilerinin ışın mikroskobu
ile görülmesi mümkün değildir? Bak çok
küçük boyuttaki nanometrik boyuttakileri
ışın mikroskobuyla göremem ama mesela
büyük olan ökaret hücreyi görebilirim.
Ökaret hücrenin içerisindeki organelleri
de ışın mikroskobuyla görebilirim. Ama
atom ve DNA'yı ışın mikroskobuyla asla
belirleyemem. Onları elektron
mikroskobuyla görebilirim. O yüzden atom
ve DNA'nın ışın mikroskobuyu ile
görülmesi mümkün değildir. Ama ökarit
hücre ve organeller görülebilir mi? Evet
görülebilir. Diyor ki milimetre ölçekli
bir cetvel ile yapılan ölçümdeki
0,001 mmik hatanın nanometre cinsinden
değeri nedir? Bak milimetreyi
nanometreye çeviriyorsam çarpıyordum.
Aradaki şey neydi? Fark 10 üzeri 6'ydı
değil mi? Milimetre ile nanometre
arasındaki fark 10 üzeri 6'ydı. O zaman
aşağı doğru gittiğim için çarptım. E bu
da ne olacak? 10 üzeri -4 x 10 üzeri
6'dan sonuç 100 nanometrelik bir hata
olduğunu fark ediyoruz. Gelelim nano
boyutu görüntüleme dediğimiz olaya. Çok
küçük tanecikleri yani nano boyutlardaki
tanecikleri elektron mikroskobuyla
görüyoruz demiştik. Mesela bizim gözümüz
neleri görebiliyor? 0,1 milimetrelik
şeyleri görebiliyor. Bu kadarcık
boyutları görebiliyor. Ama mesela bunu
işte daha küçük olduğunda gözle
göremiyoruz. Mesela kana baktığımızda
kan hücrelerini görebiliyor musun?
Hayır. Veya soğana baktığında, soğan
zarına baktığında doğrudan o hücreleri
görebiliyor musun? Hayır. Ama bunu alıp
ışın mikroskoba altına koyduğunda işte
10 üzeri -3 mmrlik kısma kadar
görebiliyorsun. Burada
gözlemleyebiliyorsun. Ama çok çok küçük
olduğundaysa burada ışığın dalga
boyundan daha küçük olduğu için ışın
mikroskobuyla göremeyiz. Peki nasıl
işlem yapacağız? İşte elektron
mikroskobu dediğimiz bir şey vardır.
Taramalı elektron mikroskobu. E ne
yapılıyor? yüzeye elektron gönderiliyor.
Elektron gönderdikten sonra oradan
belirli sinyaller, frekanslar alıyor. O
frekansları görüntüye dönüştürüyor.
Aslında doğrudan görme değil de gelen
frekansları ne yapıyor? İşte
dönüştürüyor. Ve dönüştürdüğünde mesela
işte karıncanın başına bu elektron
mikroskobuyla baktığımızda böyle bir
görüntü ortaya çıkıyor. Bak bu tablo
güzel. Buraya şöyle bir yaklaşalım
istersen. Ekrana sığdırmaya çalışıyorum
bu arada. He bak gözümüzün görebileceği
yerler. Şuraya kadarki kısım neydi? 01
mmrlik kısma kadar görüyorduk. ışı
mikroskobuyla işte 100 nanometreye yakın
değerlere kadar görebiliyorduk ama
elektron mikroskobuyla işte sıfıra yakın
yani çok küçük boyutlardaki nanometrik
boyutlarla hatta işte ışın mikroskobunun
görebileceği yerleri aslında elektron
mikroskobu da görebilmekte. Yani ışın
mikroskobu ya da ışık mikroskobu işte
belli bir yere kadar görebiliyor ama
elektron mikroskobu hem ışın
mikroskobunun gördüğü yerleri görüyor.
Eee hem de işte gözün görmediği yerleri
görmüş oluyor. Burada da gözüküyor. Göz
bunları göremiyor. Işı mikroskobu gözün
gördüğü yerleri ve işte elektron
mikroskobunun da bir kısmını gördüğü
yerleri görebiliyor. Ama elektron
mikroskobu bak görüyor musun? Şurayı
sadece o görebiliyor ki bunlar da neymiş
bak. Proteinler, yağlar, küçük
moleküller, atomlar, virüsler. Bunları
mesela neyle işte elektron mikroskobuyla
görebiliyormuşuz. Şimdi şuna bakalım.
Bana bir şey vermiş. Eşleştirme istiyor.
Burada bana bazı şeyler vermiş. Gerçek
görüntü ve elektron mikroskobu görüntüsü
kim kimle eşleşir diye soruyor. Bak şu
dokuya bakar mısın? Şuradaki dokunun
görüntüsüyle şuradaki çok benziyor değil
mi? O zaman demek ki kemik dokusunun
elektron mikroskobu altındaki görüntüsü
bu olmalı. Başka şurada sinek görüyorum.
sinek. Ya bu karınca kafası buna uygun
gibi. Hani karınca demiş de yukarıda
sinek demiş. Yani sonuçta bir böceğin
kafa kısmını neyle? Elektron
mikroskobuyla bu şekilde görebiliriz.
Başka göz var değil mi sırada? Göz. Aha
bak görüyor musun? Şuradaki görüntüyü
işte elektron mikroskobuyla görmüş.
Demek ki gözün olduğu yeri aha şununla
gözlemleyebiliriz. E ne oldu? Şu ana
kadarkileri 1i ne ile eşleştirdim? 1'i
geldim D ile eşleştirdim. Sonra 2'yi ne
ile eşleştirdim? A ile eşleştirdim. 3'e
geldiğimde onu F ile eşleştirdim. Devam
edelim. Sonra ne var? Saç teli var. Saç
teli. Aha bak burada. Görüyor musun? En
rahat burada gözüküyor. Saç telinin
görüntüsü. O zaman 4'ü de E ile
eşleştirelim. Çok güzel. Sonra ne var?
Kum var. Bak kumun içerisinde şöyle ufak
tefek parçacıklar bulunacaktır. Demek ki
5'i de B ile eşleştiriyorum. Sonra ne
var? İşte yaprak var. Aha yaprağın
üzerindeki görüntüye bu benziyor değil
mi? Yani 6'yı da kimle? C ile
eşleştirmiş oldum. Şimdi burada diyor ki
bak nanoyu görmek. Şimdi nano boyuttaki
maddeleri aslında bu nereden çıkmıştır
onu da söylemek lazım aslında. Nano
teknoloji ile ilgili ilk böyle fikir
ortaya çıktığında Lotus çiçeği diye bir
çiçek var. Bu Lotus çiçeğinin yaprağı
asla ve asla suyla ıslanmıyor. Mesela
döküyorsun suyu üzerinde böyle rahat
rahat kayıyor. Hiçbir şekilde
yapışmıyor. Ya diyorlar niye böyle? Bir
inceliyorlar. Nano boyutta böyle
hidrofobik kıllar var orada üzerinde
şeyler var. Suyun tutulmasını
engelliyormuş. Ha oradan nanoteknoloji
ortaya çıkıyor. İşte onun üzerinden
gelişmeye başlıyor. Ve şöyle bir şey
vardır. Herhangi bir maddenin normal
boyutundan nano boyutlara inildiğinde
yüzey hacim oranı artmaktadır. Yani
hacim aynı ama yüzey alanını
genişletiyorsun. Tanecik boyutlarını
küçülttüğün için şöyle düşün bak bir
tane madde var. Şöyle duruyor. Bak şu
şekilde duruyor. Kapladığı yer ne
kadardır? İşte şu zemin kadardır değil
mi? Ama bunu şu ortasından kessem yanına
koysam kapladığı yer ne oldu? Arttı. Ama
hacim aynı. Sonuçta toplam hacmi aynı.
Hatta şöyle yaptım. Birazcık daha
kestim. Bak birazcık daha kestim. Daha
büyük yer kapladı. Değil mi? Eskiden
şöyle bir yer kaplıyordu. İki'ye
böldüğümde böyle kapladı. İşte böyle
kesit kesit alıyorum ya. 4e böldüğümde
böyle kapladı. Hacim aynı ama kapladığı
alan artıyor değil mi? Bunu işte
incelttik. İncelttik. İncelttik. O kadar
incelttik ki müthiş bir genişliğe
ulaştı. İşte ne oluyor? yüzey alanı
hacim oranı artmış oluyor. Yani
kapladığı alan artmış oluyor. İşte bu
şekilde boyalar yapılıyor. Mesela bu
kullanılan boya taneciklerinin nano
boyutlara getirdiklerinde aynı yüzeyi
boyamak için belki normal boyanın %1'ini
kullanman yetiyor. Yüzeye sürdüğünde
kaplamış oluyor. Oysa ki hacim çok az
ama kapladığı yüzey çok fazla oluyor.
İşte nano boyutlardaki sistemde yüzey
alanı hacim oranı bu şekilde artmakta.
Yani bunu da söylemiş olalım. Yani ne
olmuş oluyor? maddenin yüzey alanı
büyümüş oluyor. Burada gösterdiğim gibi
yüzey alanı artışı malzemenin makro
boyuttaki özelliğinin farklı özellikler
göstermesine neden oluyor. Bu ne demek?
Şöyle söyleyeyim. İşte maddeleri nano
boyuta getirdiğimizde bazen özellikleri
değişebiliyor. İlginç bir durumdur. Onu
da söyleyelim. İşte nano parçacıkların
yani bir parçacığın nano parçacığa
dönüşmesi sonucunda yüzey alanı
genişledi. Yani yüzey alanı hacim oranı
arttı. Ama fiziksel ve kimyasal
özelliklerinde de ufak tefek
değişiklikler meydana gelebiliyor ki
bunun iyi bir örneğini şöyle göstereyim.
Bunlar tabii ki istisnai durumlardır.
Yani her maddenin kimyasal özelliği
değişir diyemiyoruz ama şöyle bir durum
vardır. Bak makro boyutta olmayan bazı
özellikler nano boyutta ortaya
çıkabilir. Ki burada söylüyor işte
çıplak gözle altına baktığımızda sarı
renklidir değil mi? He ama soymetaldir
ve şeydir. Böyle hiçbir şeyle tepkimeye
girmeyi de sevmez. Böyle asitle,
şununla, bununla hiçbir şeyle tepkimeye
girmez. Mesela bir tek kral suyuyla
girer, oksitlenmez falan. Ama ne oluyor
biliyor musun? Ben bunu alıyorum altını
nano boyutlara getirdiğimde artık sarı
olmuyor. Kırmızı renkte oluyor. Bak
ilginç bir detay. ve kimyasal tepkime de
verebiliyor. Kimyasal olarak da aktif
hale geliyor. İşte tanecikleri nano
boyuta getirdiğimizde bazen böyle ilginç
durumlar olabiliyor. Altın normalde
reaksiyon vermezken nano boyuta
getirilen altın reaksiyon verebilir hale
gelebiliyor. Başka mesela işte sadece
karbon elementinden oluşan uzayda
dizilişleri farklı grafit vardır. Bir de
grafen vardır. Mesela grafitten elde
edilir grafen nano boyutlardaki bir
yapıdır. Fiziksel ve kimyasal olarak
farklıdır. Mesela şöyle söyleyeyim.
Grafit kırılgandır. Sert bir yapıya
sahiptir. Ama grafen nano parçacıkları
halindeyken çok esnek bir yapıya
sahiptir ve çok dayanıklıdır. Bak burada
gösterilen grafendir ki geleceğin
teknolojisi olarak ifade edilir. İşte bu
elektronik kağıttı, şuydu, buydu bir
sürü şey. Yakında belki de işte sararak
cebine koyabileceğin cep telefonları
olacak. Yani bu grafenle sağlanabilir.
Bak günlük hayatta nanoteknolojiye
benzer bir ifade göstermiş. Burada küp
şekeri almış. Eşit sıcaklıkta, eşit
miktarda e çaylara, eşit miktarda küp
şeker ve toz şekeri bıraktığımda hangisi
önce çözünür? Toz şeker, değil mi? Neden
biliyor musun? İkisi de aynı miktarda
şeker olmasına rağmen şöyle bir durum
var. Bak şeyde, küp şekerde şöyle bir
durum var. Kaç tane yüzeyi var? 6 tane
yüzeyi var. Ben bu küp şekeri toz haline
getirdiğimde bir sürü küçük parçacık
var. Bak bir sürü küçük parçacık. Hacim
aynı. Toplam hacim aynı. Ama her birinin
yüzeylerini toplasana. Her bir şeker
kristalinin yüzeylerini topladığında ne
oluyor? Yüzey alanı arttı ama hacim
değişmedi. Yüzey hacim oranı arttığı
için de ne oluyor? Toz şeker daha hızlı
çözünmüş oluyor. İşte buna
benzemektedir. Şekerin yüzey hacim oranı
arttıkça çözünme oranı değişti. Yani
fiziksel özelliği değişmiş oldu. Gördün
mü? Küp şeker de var, toz şeker de var.
Ama toz şeker daha hızlı çözünüyor. İşte
çözünürlüğü, çözünme hızı daha doğrusu
ne oluyor? artmış oluyor. Fiziksel
özelliği değişmiş oluyor. İşte maddeleri
de nano boyuta getirdiğimizde fiziksel
özellikleri değişebilmekte. Şimdi gel
birazcık da örnek bakalım. Diyor ki,
"Nanoipler hastalığı tedavi etmek
amacıyla kullanılması düşünülen
malzemelerdir. Boyutları oldukça küçük
olan bu parçacıklar adeta küçük bir
kimya laboratuvarı gibidir. İlaç yan
etkilerinin tespiti için deneysel organ
görevi görebilir. Evet, söylemiştim.
Böyle bir şey vardı. Boyutları
küçüldükçe özellikleri azalır. Hayır,
özellikleri artmaktadır. Boyutlar
küçüldükçe daha böyle teknolojik şeyler
yapılabilmektedir. İçlerine
yerleştirilen çeşitli sistemler, dolaşım
boşaltım sistemleri gibi yardımıyla
yapay organ görevi de görebilmektedir.
Evet, bu da vardır. Söylemiştim. E ne
oldu o zaman? Cevabımız D seçeneği.
Şimdi şu sorumuza bakalım. Diyor ki,
"Yukarıdaki maddelerin nanometre
cinsinden yarıçaplarının
karşılaştırılması aşağıdakilerden
hangisine doğru verilmiştir?" diyor.
Hım, bakalım. Şimdi insan saç deli ya
bunun boyutu büyüktür. Hücre zarı var,
grip virüsü var. Bunlara göre büyüktür.
E grip virüsününki yaklaşık 20
nanometreydi. Hücre zarı ise 12 nanom
falandı. Yani grip virüsü birazcık daha
büyüktür. Kimden? Hücre zarından. E ne
olacak o zaman sıralama? 1 3 2 var mı? 1
3 2. Evet. Cevabımız E seçeneği. Burada
aloe vera bitkisinden bahsediyor. Bunun
ne yapmış? İşte bir normal görüntüsünü
vermiş. Bir de SEM görüntüsünü yani
elektron mikroskobu görüntüsünü vermiş
ve diyor ki hangileri doğrudur? İkinci
haldeki görüntü aloe vera herhangi bir
yaprağının elektron tarayıcılardan
geçirilmesiyle elde edilir. Elektron
mikroskobu böyle bir şeydi. Evet bu var
doğru. İkinci görüntü birinci
görüntüdeki yaprak kesitinden herhangi
birinin 100 kat küçültülmüş halidir.
Hayır çok çok daha küçültülmüş halidir.
Gitti. Diyor ki ikinci görüntü ışık
mikroskobu ile elde edilmiştir. Hayır bu
SEM görüntüsüydü. Sem görüntüsü olduğunu
söylemiştik. ışın mikroskobunda böyle
olmayacaktır. Birazcık daha böyle kaba
gözükecektir. Bu tüm detaylarına kadar
gözüküyor. O yüzden cevap yalnız bir A
seçeneği. Burada diyor ki yukarıdaki
ifadelerden hangileri doğrudur? Aynı
maddenin makro ve nano boyuttaki
özellikleri tamamen aynıdır. Hayır.
Fiziksel özellikleri farklı
olabiliyordu. Kimyasallarda da
değişimler olabiliyor demiştik. Nano
boyuta indikçe maddenin hacmi ve yüzey
alanı aynı oranda artar. Hayır. Hacmi
değişmiyordu. Neredeyse değişmiyordu ama
yüzey alanı artıyordu. Yüzey alanı bölü
hacim oranı ciddi bir şekilde artıyordu.
O yüzden bu ifade yanlıştır. Diyor ki
mikro boyuttaki tüm görüntüler nano
boyutta görülebilir. Evet. Işın
mikroskobu mikro boyuttakileri
görebiliyordu. O yüzden nano boyutta da
görülebilmektedir. Yani elektron
mikroskobu da o bölgeyi görüyordu zaten.
Doğrudur. O yüzden cevabımız ne
olacaktır? Yalnız 3 B seçeneği. Evet.
Burada bir ara verelim. Biraz
dinlenelim. Zaten sözel bir konu
gördüğün gibi. Günlük hayattan
bahsediyoruz. Birazcık böyle genel
kültür bilgileri veriyoruz. Burada bir
tek işte işlemli kısım o nanometreyi
işte çevirme işlemleri, milimetre ve
metreye çevirme işlemleri. Onlara da
şöyle bir bakarsın. Bir daha o listeye
bakmanı tavsiye ediyorum. Beni
dinlediğin için teşekkür ederim. Bu
videoların devamının gelmesi için kanala
abone olmanı, arkadaşlarına tavsiye
etmeni, beğenmeni arada bir de yorum
yapmanı istiyorum değerli dostum. İki
fosfor asit kimya bu kadar basit.
Görüşmek üzere.